and this is
this is what we need to watch out for
well this is this is what we need to
watch out for this authoritarian mindset
look do you need to watch out for it as
a nation yes you better especially as
things start getting imposed on your on
your life
because that slides into
authoritarianism
and that's that's a slippery slope and i
know that you're going to bring up the
slippery slope fallacy
well i see it in your eyes
again and i'll say that i said it before
where there is such thing as a slippery
slope and there is such thing as a
slippery slope fallacy they're not like
one doesn't you know they both exist
they both exist exactly right
so authoritarianism
in our minds
we have to watch out for it
in our teams as leaders we have to watch
out for it and yes as human beings
living in a whatever country you live in
you need to watch out for that
authoritarianism because
it's a thing that once it starts to take
hold the authoritarian it snowballs yeah
like i get a little bit of control
authoritarian people when they get a
little bit of control they want more
control yeah and then they get a little
bit more they want even more and they
don't stop
and it's a it's a
it's a psychopathology that they have
that they can't contain it
so here we go authoritarianism in
discussing military organizations it was
suggested that a symbiotic relationship
exists between certain characteristics
of armed services and the private needs
of the individual members so what that's
saying is when you go in the military
there's certain needs that certain
people have certain psychological needs
that people have that going in the
military satisfies those needs for
instance here's a here's an example of
where this is a bad thing i like to rule
over people
i know if i become an officer in the
military i'll be able to rule over those
privates
so it sort of
satisfies
that to me
so there's a nice relationship i have i
want to be an authoritarian this puts me
in an authoritarian position i love it
is this true of all military people no
it's not continuing on emphasis was laid
upon the central role in this
relationship of anxiety that insidious
motivator of such of much human behavior
in the military mind it was pointed out
anxiety has many sources fear of death
and mutilation fear of suppression
fear of failure and social disapproval
fear of public disgrace and underlying
all that fear of total disorder
which is inseparable product of
unleashing normally tabooed instinctual
forces so if you're a person that
doesn't like disorder
you look at the military and go on
that looks pretty good you got to go to
bed at a certain time all these people
will listen to me we get to follow
orders they're going to tell me what to
do everyone's going to listen to when i
tell them what to do
that's you you're if you don't like
disorder that's a great place to be
until what happens
the layer of total disorder on planet
earth
opens its jaws and that is combat so now
you're a person that doesn't like
disorder and for your job at the moment
of truth you are thrust into the jaws of
the highest level of disorder in the
world that is combat
and that's why this is that's what this
book is about this psychology of
military incompetence is because people
that like order and join the military
because they like order and then their
actual job look part of their job is
marching around a parade field and
inspecting uniforms and keeping
everything squared away that's great but
the when that when that homie shows up
and shit's getting crazy
they lose their
minds so when you're looking when you're
judging and you're thinking oh what if
that bad guy be a good military officer
they're highly disciplined
they're highly disciplined they they
they follow orders they're authoritarian
they seem like they'd be great you need
to remember what's that person gonna do
when things get wild
and they're gonna get wild
continuing on finally it was suggested
and you can see where this whole book
that little that
that crux that's why i said this is the
crux of the book that crux right there
is why this is so fascinating to me
because i've seen this throughout my
career
people that were squared away people
that were
highly disciplined people that were
loved for things to be in order and when
things weren't going right or things
were getting wild they'd lose their
minds
and by the way if they never got put
into a situation where things got wild
they get promoted by the way they're
getting promoted because they're the
most ordered they kept the tightest
reigns on their troops